ces cinquante mille actions et non dix
mille de la société américaine rachetée
par le groupe industriel français
un effet de la politique d'ouverture de
moscou par dizaines de milliers des
ressortissants allemands installés dans
les pays de l'est après la deuxième
guerre mondiale réintègre l'allemagne de
l'ouest
rugby tournoi des six nations les petits
ont souffert pour leur premier match
contre l'irlande après avoir été mené
pendant les trois quarts de la rencontre
les français l'ont finalement emporté 26
à 21
madame monsieur bonsoir
à chaque jour sa révélation dans la
sphère pechiney si les acteurs sont
particulièrement discret la presse fait
son travail et des découvertes ainsi le
journal le monde daté de ce samedi
après-midi affirme que roger patrice
pelât l'un des amis les plus proches de
monsieur mitterrand a acquis à bon prix
des actions triangle de la société
américaine rachetée par p chine roger
patrice pelât aurait en fait acheté 50
mille actions au lieu des dix mille dont
il avait reconnu dans un premier temps
l'acquisition cette information sur
laquelle le porte parole du président ne
veut faire aucun commentaire
renouvelant sa confiance dans la
commission des opérations de bourse qui
mène l'enquêté ramène tout de même ce
soir là faire vers l'elysée claire
chazal dans la sphère pechiney c'est
aujourd'hui la piste française qui
ressort avec un homme
roger patrice pelât ami du chef de
l'état selon le journal le monde
monsieur plat aurait acquis non plus dix
mille mais au total cinquante mille
titres triangle dont quarante mille
achetés via la banque cantonale vaudoise
ainsi les hommes d'affaires français
soupçonné parmi lesquels un autre proche
du parti socialiste
max théret aurait ramassé à eux tous
près de la moitié des actions
illégalement acquises à la bourse de new
york reste par ailleurs la piste suisse
suivie par les enquêteurs américains
avec surtout une banque helvétique
soko finances derrière laquelle se cache
la société idb
et aux caraïbes mais ce soir les
questions demeurent des spéculateurs
moyen-orientaux sont-ils mêlée à la
faire samir traboulsi quant à lui ni
détenir un compte chez soko finances
enfin et surtout qui parmi les
négociateurs de l'accord pechiney
triangle à renseigner les acheteurs
français et étrangers la suite dans
cette affaire un homme a déjà
démissionné hier après midi de son poste
monsieur alain boublil directeur de
cabinet du ministre de l'économie et des
finances monsieur bérigaud ce matin dans
une interview au figaro il affirme
qu'ils ne se laissera pas faire
qu'il a l'intention d'attaquer en
diffamation certains journaux enfin il
fait le point sur ses relations avec un
intermédiaire libanais de la sphère
pechiney monsieur samir traboulsi
élisabéthaine à propos de ce qui est
pour lui le dossier et non pas la sphère
pechiney dans le figaro de ce matin
alain boublil se défend premièrement
d'avoir eu des contacts avec patrice
pelât et max théret au moment du rachat
de la société américaine triangle
deuxièmement d'avoir eu des relations
trop étroites avec samir traboulsi alain
boublil rappellent qu'ils étaient amis
depuis six ans avec l'homme d'affaires
libanais et qu'il n'avait aucune raison
de ne plus le voir au moment des
négociations
tout comme il n'avait pas à refuser des
vacances avec sa famille l'été dernier
sur le yacht de traboulsi en corse il y
a bien rencontré des responsables de
pechiney et le vendeur américain nelson
peltz mais il nie avoir participé de
près ou de loin à toute discussion
d'affaires
enfin l'ancien directeur de cabinet de
pierre bérégovoy se défend d'être riche
il affirme ne posséder aucun bien
immobilier et n'a même pas fini de payer
une r5 acheté d'occasion
voilà pour les faits le commentaire
maintenant tout au long de cette semaine
plusieurs pistes ont été évoquées dans
cette affaire du rachat de la société
américaine american can par la société
française pechiney piste américaine
piste suisse moyen-orientale et ce soir
donc retour vers l'elysée et au travers
du meilleur ami de monsieur mitterrand
le président une ville-clé oui tous ces
derniers jours les projecteurs s'étaient
bien concentrés essentiellement sur la
rue de rivoli jusqu'à la démission du
directeur de cabinet
de pierre bérégovoy on avait pu imaginer
qu au moins jusqu'aux conclusions
publiques de la commission des
opérations de bourse
cette affaire connaîtrait un répit ce
soir visiblement il n'en est rien le
balancier il vient de revenir avec
fracas jusqu'à l'elysée avec une cible
le président de la république même par
personne interposée
roger patrice pelât est un proche de
françois mitterrand
plus encore un ami aujourd'hui il
éclabousse son compagnon de résistance
l'elysée avertit depuis hier de ces
informations
rappelons le toujours conditionnel reste
sur sa ligne de conduite
pas question de couvrir qui que ce soit
même parmi les plus proches françois
mitterrand fait confiance aux travaux de
la cob et à la justice mais toujours
dans l'entourage du président on observe
ce soir que les dégâts sont déjà
considérables pour la gauche d'abord
pour le gouvernement suit pour l'image
du président enfin pour l'image de la
france à l'extérieur alors qu'une série
de questions restent toujours poser
encore et toujours qui a donné
l'information du rachat d'american
cannes par péchiney pourquoi si
l'information du monde est exact ce
double achats de roger patrice pelât
l'un en clair l'autre par intermédiaire
et surtout pour qui ou pour quelle
opération la sphère ne pourra plus
désormais s'arrêter sans réponses
précises à ses questions
et parmi les réactions ce soir qui sont
assez peu nombreuses tout de même celle
à l'instant de monsieur jean jacques
queyranne porte parole du parti
socialiste qui vient de déclarer il n'y
a pas de protection particulière en
régime de droit qui est le régime de la
france et il n'y a pas de relation entre
cette mise en cause de monsieur plat et
la situation politique
pas de réaction du côté de l'opposition
eurent paix rhdp est rude et f pour
l'instant en revanche à l'occasion de sa
première journée de conventions
municipal le président du front national
monsieur jean marie le pen prononce le
mot démission à propos de monsieur
mitterrand s'il se révélait que celui ci
était vraiment compromis roland sicard
philippe dumas
le front national annonce la couleur du
tricolore partout pas question de ranger
son drapeau dans sa poche lorsque les
élections approchent ou que les affaires
secoue la classe politique et jean marie
le pen donne le taux certes lorsqu'il se
lance dans l'analyse
le leader de l'extrême droite se montre
modéré explique que ce ne sont pas les
hommes mais le système socialiste ce qui
accusait pourtant très vite le goût de
la petite phrase reprend le dessus et
jean marie le pen sort l'artillerie
lourde
s'il s'avérait qu'en effet dans une
affaire comme celle-là touchant
gravement aux intérêts du peuple
français et à la réputation de la france
le président de la république se trouve
à compromis je pense qu'il devrait tirer
des conclusions que pour sa part
monsieur couple il simple fonctionnaire
a attiré tout naturellement ça veut dire
que pour vous le président de
démissionner je pense en effet oui qu'
on ne voit pas pourquoi il aurait une
conscience plus élastique que c'est de
monsieur boublil jean marie le pen qui
monte au créneau
l'extrême droite a sans doute trouvé son
thème de campagne
le front national loin des affaires se
présente comme le champion de la
moralité l'occasion à moins de deux mois
des municipales de redorer son blason
justement à ce propos monsieur jean
marie le pen a dit qu'il allait se
présenter dans le 20e arrondissement de
paris
dans ce contexte interrogé il y a quinze
jours entre le 9 et 16 janvier par
l'ifop pour le compte du journal du
dimanche et les français étaient 47% à
ceux déclarés plutôt satisfaits du
président de la république contre 46 au
mois de décembre 38 % de mécontents
contre 39% en décembre pour ce qui
concerne le premier ministre monsieur
michel rocard 43% de satisfaits contre
37 en décembre mais comptant 35 contre
40 en décembre concours de circonstances
ce week-end à paris se tient un salon
intitulé investir et placé qui remporte
d'ailleurs un grand succès les français
depuis 1983 c'est un passionné pour la
finance nos reporters marque maisonneuve
et yann gicquel on en profitait pour
voir si les visiteurs étaient troublés
ou non pas ce qui se passe en ce moment
sur dix mille mètres carrés un salon
consacré à l'épargné qui s'affiche ici
le premier jeu capitaliste un produit en
chine mais si on peut tout faire pour
placer son argent oeuvres d'art
portefeuille d'actions immobilier on
peut aussi le perdre
je suis pas masochiste mais j'ai
toujours confiance dans les blocs monde
pour quelles raisons
parce que en 88 la bourse à près de 40%
en 87 elle a perdu 30 et des broutilles
2% alors il faut regarder enfin regarder
avec le recul entre 84 et 88 l'épargné
des ménages demeurent sensiblement la
même
l'argent envolé dans le krach de 87 la
connaissance de délit d'initié rien ne
ralentit l'intérêt des particuliers
l'argent attire même si certaines
indélicatesses paraissent condamnable
vous allez continuer de passer l'argent
telepath et dénonçait pas qu'on respecte
et on veut réaliser au moment où on a
besoin d'aller travailler
la facilité avec laquelle on parle
d'argent étonne dans les travées on
cherche capitalisation assurance-vie
complément retraite il y a des formes de
placement sûr et puis il ya les autres
ceux qui ressemblent à des jeux réservés
aux seuls connaisseurs ils sont à haut
risque chacun en a conscience
d'autant que les notions morale seyfried
devant l'attrait de l'argent comme si
après tout les voleurs que celui qui se
fait prendre
monsieur michel charasse le ministre du
budget dont on sait qu'il a le verbe
haut et fort parfois se fait encore
remarquer par une violente diatribe à
l'égard de la compagnie aérienne air
inter il estime que celle ci se fout du
monde ce sont ses propres termes
au départ de la sphère le ministre
bloqués à l'aéroport de clermont ferrand
sont qu'on lui en donne les raisons
exactes réactions des intéressés ce
matin à orly stéphane magnier didier da
orly ouest ce matin tout à luxe calme et
volupté d'un aérogare de dépliants
publicitaires on est à mille lieues de
la précipitation de gestes d'énervement
des hommes d'affaires pendant la semaine
peu d'attentes à l'achat des billets pad
annonce de retard à deux km an à
l'enregistrement et bien malgré cette
atmosphère détendue de début de week end
r à terre a une réputation qui ne se
fait pas oublier
j'm'en l'avion trois ou quatre fois par
semaine au moins une fois de la semaine
ya un problème quand vous avez du retard
est ce qu'on vous explique pourquoi
nous disent qu'on veut bien le dire mais
enfin je surfe a contrôlé environ le
tiers des passagers que nous avons
interrogés a repris une complainte qui
ressemble fort à celle de monsieur
charasse c'est trop sévère et la faute à
pas de chance
répondant à la compagnie nous avons
rencontré des difficultés sociales et on
comptait des difficultés de navigation
aérienne depuis le dernier trimestre
depuis quatre mois maintenant
car à terre c'est très peu parler d'elle
elle tourne
le ch arras a eu un retard important
un jour où dix aéroports français ont
été touchés par le brouillard et où
effectivement nous avons une
désorganisation complète de nos systèmes
d'avion qui nous a amenés non plusieurs
aéroports dont celui de clermont ferrand
à avoir trois heures de retard
embêtant quand même ces critiques
ministériel à l'eau de 92 et de
l'inauguration du tgv atlantique
quant à l'information du public c'est
promis des 89
ah ça ira ça ira justement il ya quand
même des choses qui vont bien tout de
même la société alstom et la sncf grâce
au tgv remportent des succès à
l'étranger notamment récemment en
espagne
et puis l'inauguration cette semaine du
tgv atlantique qui non seulement va très
très vite
mais qui est également une magnifique
machine jacques violet jean corne ou
deux générations deux tgv qui se
croisent huit ans les séparent
le nouveau argent et bleue continue
entre paris et lyon les essais les
dernières mises au point en huit ans
beaucoup de changement et d'amélioration
le profil plus pointu et un carénage
plus aérodynamique les moteurs ils sont
synchrones c'est à dire à la fois plus
légers et plus puissant il utilise du
courant triphasé au lieu du continu pour
une masse comparable au tgv sud-est
l'atlantique à une puissance double la
suspension point noir du grand frère a
été considérablement améliorée
aujourd'hui une suspension pneumatique
de l'air comprimé et des normes
amortisseurs donne une meilleure assise
plus aucune vibration la vitesse c'est
aussi le freinage quatre doubles disques
en acier non ventilées
les franc surpuissant l'équivalent d'un
abs pour les voitures toutes ces
améliorations techniques dû à
l'expérience donne à 300 kilomètres
heure la vitesse commerciale de ce
nouveau train le confort d'une voiture
corail classique à 160 dans la cabine
l'électronique et l'informatique assiste
le mécanicien contrôler la vitesse et
surveille l'état de marche de la ram en
temps réel
à bord une capacité plus importante
485 passagers par rame au lieu de 386
sur le sud-est l'intérieur des voitures
a également été très largement revu on a
diversifié les espaces petit salon en
première compartiment pour les familles
des groupes espace pour enfants
enfin une voiture complètement consacré
aux barres et à la restauration et 2
publiphones à 40 pour la sncf
une augmentation importante de trafic
vers l'ouest ce train va prendre comme
sur lyon beaucoup de passagers à l'avion
et la voiture mais également des
passagers nouveau nous pensons que sur
le tgv atlantique comme sur le tgv sud
est la présence d'un nouveau moyen de
transport performant va créer de
nouveaux besoins de transport et que
nous aurons environ 40% d'induction de
pratique du simplement à l'existence de
ce nouveau mode en région parisienne on
termine les travaux sur la ligne
nouvelle
on pose la caténaire la ligne électrique
et l'on achèvent les finitions dans les
tunnels
à partir du mois de septembre prochain
paris le mans en une heure paris rennes
ou nantes 2 heures le tgv nouveau est
arrivé
fait divers tragique insupportable à
bourges une fillette de 8 ans retrouvée
morte dans l'appartement situé juste en
face de celui de ses parents 24 heures
après sa disparition le locataire cet
appartement ça q ce soir du meurtre de
la petite fille qui ricanaient g égorgé
céline à bourges
l'aveu de vincent clerc 36 ans qui vient
de se constituer prisonnier à paris le
corps de la fillette venait d'être
découvert dans une valise égorgé après
avoir subi des sévices sexuels
en rentrant de l'école vendredi soir
céline huit ans monte dans cet ascenseur
arrivé au sixième étage l'horreur juste
en face de l'appartement des parents
céline une petite fille timide et
méfiante
comme souvent dans ces cas le meurtrier
ressemble à monsieur tout le monde
les voisins s'étonne et manifestent leur
soutien à la famille miller ue les
parents vincent clerc lui subit en ce
moment même
interrogatoire dans le 10e
arrondissement à paris c'est le cartable
de céline découvert dans l'appartement
qui l'a trahi
il semble que l'homme se soit livré
spontanément à la police
la suite de l' enquête nous apprendra
peut-être les raisons de son acte
les expertises psychiatriques nous en
dirons certainement davantage
harlem désir le président de sos racisme
parle d'abus de confiance envers les
immigrés qui depuis le discours du
président de la république la nouvelle
année en leur faveur se présente en
masse dans les préfectures françaises
croyant que la loi facilitant leur
insertion et déjà voté en fait dit
harlem désir et bien nous avons le
sentiment que certains préfets en
profite pour ficher certains immigrés
expulser ceux qui sont en situation
irrégulière après les propositions de
réforme de l'enseignement présentés
cette semaine par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur jospin
les instituteurs du sc nice favorable
sur le fond à ce projet estiment qu'ils
sont dans cette affaire traitée en
inférieur en conséquence de quoi ils
appellent à une grève mercredi grève
également des professeurs des lycées
professionnels
à l'appel de la cgt pour vendredi
prochain la cgt
n'acceptant pas l'idée d'un jugement
individuel sur les enseignants et d'une
carrière réalisés au mérite
à l'étranger la politique d'ouverture
prônée par moscou ne passe pas encore
par la tchécoslovaquie visiblement où
règne une des plus vieilles équipes
communiste au pouvoir dans cette partie
du monde
chaque soir depuis une semaine les
manifestations à la mémoire de jan
palach cet étudiant qui s'était immolé
par le feu pour protester contre
l'entrée de l'armée rouge en
tchécoslovaquie en 1968 eh bien ces
manifestations sont dispersés sans
ménagement gilles ragon
jan polak est vivant et nous nous
n'avons plus peur
malgré l'interdiction officielle et la
milice pour la sixième fois en six jours
la même foule revient sur les mêmes
pavés de la place venceslas de prague ou
en 68 à 20 ans yann pas là que s'était
immolé par le feu pour protester contre
l'intervention des chars russes en
tchécoslovaquie pour la sixième fois en
six jours
la police et la milice charge le pouvoir
ne veut pas entendre ces manifestants
crier que la pérestroïka de gorbatchev
ne fait que reprendre les grandes idées
lancées il ya 20 ans par le printemps de
prague les provocateurs pour le pouvoir
encore en place
des épaves politique qui bénéficie je
cite du soutien réactionnaire de l'ouest
au contraire pourrait-on dire
conséquences de l'ouverture voulue
directement par moscou cette fois ci des
habitants de plusieurs pays de l'est
d'origine allemande dispersés dans ces
pays après la deuxième guerre mondiale
obtiennent aujourd'hui par milliers par
dizaines de milliers le droit de
réintégrer l'allemagne de l'ouest de
bonnes l'enquète de notre correspondant
philippe rochot
il porte les vêtements que l'on met dans
les villages du kazakhstan dé campagne
de pologne de roumanie ils ont des
passeports des pays de l'est
et pourtant ils sont allemands
transportés par l'histoire ils sont 3
millions à vivre encore de l'autre côté
du rideau de fer
mais pour la première fois il rentre en
masse au pays
c'est l'un des résultats de la politique
de la transparence la glace nost et des
meilleures relations entre l'est et
l'ouest pour quitter les états de l'est
ils ont dû prouver leur origine
allemande par des certificats ou des
actes de naissance des formalités qui
ont duré parfois dix ans comme pour ce
couple venu de roumanie ils ont tous
laissé de la famille là-bas ils ont peur
de parler
j'ai ma famille ici et trois enfants la
famille roumaine et ne parle pas
l'allemand
j'espère trouver du travail je suis
peintre en bâtiment je suis content
d'être en allemagne les gens sont
gentils avec nous
arrivé le matin même de roumanie la
famille carole apparaît presque
privilégiées elle comprend l'entretien
avec le professeur qui va dresser son
portrait pour qu'elle puisse trouver un
travail
il parlait l'allemand à la maison ils
ont étudié pendant huit ans et les
enfants en roumanie sont allés à l'école
allemande
ce certificat va les orienter dans leur
nouvelle vie
ils viennent en allemagne parce qu'ils
sont allemands roumanie il y encore pour
eux des écoles allemandes n'est plus les
gens partent et moins ces écoles ont des
chances de survivre
la deuxième vie de ces allemands venus
de l'est elle a commencé ici à
l'aéroport de francfort
c'est l'allemagne fédérale qui a payé
leur voyage de moscou de bucarest ou de
varsovie ici des allemands venus du
kazakhstan et de roumanie ils avaient
tous de la famille installée déjà en
allemagne fédérale pour récupérer ses
nationaux le gouvernement allemand doit
payer le pays d'où ils viennent
quarante mille francs pour ceux qui
arrivent de roumanie bucarest autorise à
présent 14000 roumain d'origine
allemande a quitté le pays chaque année
700 familles se retrouvent ainsi en
bavière dans cet immeuble de la banlieue
de nuremberg en attendant un passeport
allemand
un lieu de résidence un travail deux
cent mille personnes sont arrivées en 88
afflux sans précédent mais en 89
il en viendra à 250 milles
à leur arrivée ils reçoivent chacun des
rations alimentaires 70 francs par jour
il reste d'ici une semaine où ils sont
logés nourris avant d'affronter une
réalité qu'ils ne connaissent pas
certains parlent pas pénalement alors on
teste leur niveau de langue en leur
demandant de répondre aux questions de
quelle ville venez vous quel est votre
profession pour eux l'allemagne fédérale
doit construire en deux ans 45 mille
logements
les polonais sont les plus nombreux
viennent ensuite les soviétiques
les roumains et les yougoslaves ils sont
répartis dans les différents états
régionaux
selon le pays d'où ils viennent ils
doivent vivre souvent pendant plusieurs
mois dans une seule pièce par famille il
faut souvent remonter à trois ou quatre
générations pour trouver leur origine
allemande
même si le retour de ces gens permet à
l'allemagne de contourner provisoirement
le problème de la dénatalité
ils resteront souvent des étrangers dans
ce qui est pourtant devenu leur propre
pays
économie notre rubrique bons points du
samedi ce soir bon point pour un coup de
coeur le nom d'une société que beaucoup
d'entre vous connaissent sûrement
notamment lé plus jeunes coup de coeur
c'était au début des caleçons puis des
chaussons et aujourd'hui toute une gamme
de vêtements qui s'exporte largement à
l'origine il y a 6 ans à peine une
styliste et un publicitaire invente un
gadget qui l'ont transformé en véritable
industrie reportage
jacques violet frédéric bazille
le secret de cette réussite deux jeunes
et une idée simple un produit commercial
le caleçon et un slogan
le tout avec une volonté farouche de
gagner moi je tire la publicité il ya
six ans et puis j'ai rencontré une jeune
fille qui avait énormément de talent qui
s'appelle ex de rivarol qui faisait des
caleçons dans sa chambre j'ai un énorme
coup de coeur pour ces produits et je me
suis dit ah peut-être un truc derrière
dont je suis allé voir la voir un jour j
écoute avec des produits plus la marque
que j'ai déposée qui est coup de coeur
on peut peut-être faire un truc j'ai
passé centre à thèmes on peut essayer
laventure comment 183 ils vendent
lesquels sont à leurs copains puis aux
amis des copains
très vite il faut trouver des fabricants
qui jouent le jeu une entreprise de
seine maritime a même modifié ses
machines
aujourd'hui la production atteint 100
mille qu'elles sont par mois à la chaîne
4 minutes par caleçon en cinq ans coup
de coeur est devenue une véritable
entreprise 80 personnes dont cinq
stylistes travail à temps plein moyenne
d'âge 24 ans elle dessine les motifs des
tissus choisissent les couleurs et les
modèles avec les commerciaux
après les caleçons les chemises des
pyjamas les tee shirts et les
charentaises il vingtaine de produits
toujours de bon goût et qui ne se
prennent pas au sérieux
une espèce de clins d'oeil auquel on ne
résiste pas au coeur c'est ce truc qui
fait craquer donc on passe dans un
magasin et puis on voit un beau tissu un
beau produit et puis on envie d'acheter
on n'est pas vraiment prévu d'acheter au
des papiers comme l'emballage est beau
comme le produit est beau et ben on
craque
cette équipe de jeunes a effectivement
réussi à faire craquer des millions de
clients aujourd'hui on débite les tissus
au kilomètre le caleçon avec un million
d'exemplaires par an ne représentent
plus que 20 % de la production chiffre
d'affaires 80 830 millions de francs
dont 25 % à l'exportation
quittons les caleçons pour le
bicentenaire de la révolution
bicentenaire oblige ce matin et bien
certains républicains se sont souvenus
que le 21 janvier 1793 à 10h10 très
exactement j'ai noté et bien louis saez
avaient été décapités a paris une
centaine de personnes s'étaient donc
réunis place de la concorde ce matin
pour fêter c'est bien le terme
cette exécution en revanche dans un
château de l'oise une famille d'euros
la liste comme nom réel dans le même
temps et dans le recueillement la mort
du roi jean marc brami claude bard le
château déchets rei de la rivière ce 21
janvier 1989 et tant d'aisance génie on
commémore sous le regard du petit louis
17 le 21 janvier 1793 date de
l'exécution de louis saez ici on les
monarchistes légitimiste dont catholique
est épris de tradition de père en fils
de roulement vivre chez ces gens là
monsieur on vilipende la gueuse
entendait la république un peu
provocateur l'année du bicentenaire ce
bicentenaire du diable est notre chance
et pensez vous sincèrement que la
majorité des français a besoin ou envie
d'un roi eh bien je ne dirais pas ça je
ne crois pas que la pour l'instant les
français ont envie d'arbres il dira il
en rêve de plus en plus je ne crois pas
être à phénomène
si demain vous aviez un enfant est ce
que vous supporteriez échoué aux
républicains enfin il serait
certainement réalise pas ce que les
enfants bien élevés ressemblent autant
les grands parents et mes arrière grands
pères et grand mère m'ont appris la
royauté et sequalum royauté la royauté c
silence éloquent malgré un sens inné de
la famille décidément la monarchie n'est
plus ce qu'elle était le château
familial est cerné d'un caravaning
férocement républicain après la réalité
est bien le cinéma festival du film
fantastique à avoriaz c'est le soir des
résultats le premier prix a été attribué
à un film canadien faux semblants
français de david cronenberg sur place
nos envoyés spéciaux jean jacques dufour
jean françois cheveux la neige que l'on
attendait depuis longtemps tombe enfin
les récompenses aussi cette année deux
grands prix avoriaz le prix de l'étrange
et le prix du fantastique
monsieur terrain stand président du 17e
festival pardon va nous donner le nom
des vainqueurs de grand prise
fantastique et dead ringers elle grand
prix et tranches basses faux semblants
de david cronenberg est donc le grand
prix fantastiques de cette année c'est
l'histoire de deux jumeaux qui partagent
tous jusqu'au jour où avec jeremy iron
ce qui réussit une superbe performance
d'acteur
le grand prix de l'étrange c'est pas
peur à ousse de bernard aux premiers
films de cet angle est très connu pour
ses clips
il avait notamment réalisé celui de
frankie goes to hollywood relaxe c'est
l'histoire d'une petite fille qui arriva
à contrôler ses rêves par
l'intermédiaire de ses dessins
son de film magnifique avec des
performances d'acteurs qui sont très
riches et qui sont plus psychologique
que violent voilà donc pour le festival
d'avoriaz un mot encore à figueras en
espagne où il est hospitalisé depuis
hier le peintre salvador dali 84 ans est
toujours considéré dans un état
désespéré une lente agonie une lente
agonie a déclaré l'un de ses médecins le
sport pour terminer rugby tournoi des
cinq nations vous l'avez sans doute
suivi en direct cet après midi sur notre
chaîne et bien les chers petits de notre
regretté toujours regretté roger couderc
ont eu très chaud cet après midi à
dublin pour leur premier match contre
l'irlande
eh bien ils ont été menés très largement
au score pendant les trois quarts de la
rencontre avant que je vous rassure de
l'emporter 26 à 21 francis marotte
irlande france une heure de jeu lorsque
franck mesnel décide d'enfoncer la
défense irlandaise oublier les coups de
pied de pénalité les quelques coups de
poing place aux coups d'éclat les
français ne s'en laissent plus conter
ils prennent même le jeu à leur compte
blanco carminati la faune avant et
arrière dans une volonté commune allait
balle en main vers l'en but adverse 45
secondes de jeu à la main pour des
joueurs qui se redouble qui se
dédoublent la faune encore carminati
toujours berbizier à nouveau pour franck
mesnel toujours là et berbizier qui
cette fois ouvre au large la balle à
blanc coûts qui marque la france a enfin
trouvé son chemin
pourtant tout commence mal pour les
tricolores en première mi temps
chandelle de paul dean blanco la foule
s'en lasse me line passes et inscrit les
premiers points 0 landais c'est ensuite
la ballade irlandaise de pénalité en
pénalités kiernan en grange
- sous l'oeil complaisant de l' arbitre
écossais 15 0 avant le premier réveil
français jean-baptiste lafond servi par
serge blanco inscrit les quatre premiers
points de l'équipe de france mais à la
mi-temps l'irlande virant à 18 cette
logique nous n'avons pas eu beaucoup de
ballons en touche en première période
surtout lors de la première partie de
cette première période et il est
toujours difficile de créer samba lors
des ballons en deuxième mi temps il y en
a plus beaucoup plus même dès lors les
arrières s'enivre de jeu à la main blanc
coup pour philippe sella
c'est là lagisquet et la france revient
à sept points des irlandais trois
minutes plus tard la france revient même
à un point grâce à ce fabuleux mouvement
conclut donc par serge blanco
enfin à sept minutes du coup de sifflet
final sur cette touche tout d'abord est
ce regroupement
ensuite les français feront le tour du
terrain pour aller inscrire leur
quatrième essai le deuxième de patrice
lagisquet victoire finale donc 26 21
mais attention tout de même à ne pas
renouveler trop souvent le scénario
catastrophe de cette première mi temps
voilà pour l'information du jour
j'ajoute simplement leurs résultats du
tiercé et du kart et qui s'est couru cet
après midi à vincennes pour gagner il
fallait jouer le 15 sept
et le 6 un beau tiercé 19 mille francs
et puis le quartier vous ajoutez le 2 et
vous gagnez 193 1600 francs et 20
centimes que vous ramassez sur le
comptoir tout de suite après ce journal
est bien il y aura la météo avec à bages
et même les pronostics de demain
pronostic de pierrette brès pour demain
voilà un supplément au programme
je vous laisse le temps de regarder 4 13
14 3 1 19 cette voie là jouez vous
gagnerez sans doute peut-être en tout
cas donc j'en reviens à ma météorite
tout de suite josé qui vous présente ça
tout de suite après le journal champs
elysées ce soir avec notamment nana
mouskouri dernier journal de philippe
gassot aux alentours de 23 heures 25
quant à nous si vous voulez bien on se
retrouve demain à 13h bonsoir bonne
soirée sur notre chaîne
ouais